now we can actually use this result and
we can think about the rules that we
already know and work out cause and tear
okay about this the derivative odds
pause okay now I could do this whole
exercise again okay and you would notice
the same thing okay but let's see if we
can do this another way because you guys
know how to deal with this kind of thing
if this is in terms of a function you
already know now sine and cosine right
does anyone know what the code in cosine
stands for maternal relation
it stands for compliment not as you know
not as in nice haircut but as it adds up
to 90 rates pine - right in other words
when you have cosine of X okay that's
actually sign off sharp there degrees on
it 90 degrees - next okay that's an
identity that you can test it out you
know cause of xx is equal to sine of 70
or a more common example sine of 30 is
positive 60 okay
they add up to 90 degrees you're happy
so therefore what can I put in here this
is the derivative of sine 90 degrees
minus of X okay now what rule do we need
the differentials this is a function you
could use best Princip so we are going
to in a second but you guys know faster
way sure you don't faster with this
chain rule isn't it
sine is a function and then you've got
90 degrees minus X which is also a
function right so how does chain will
work you do the inside then you do the
outside what's the derivative of the
inside it's just just the coefficient
what's the derivative of the outside its
side so it should turn into cars
okay now this is true but I can do it a
bit neater because I just stand you know
up here
this relationship is reciprocal so cause
of 90 minus X is sine now on a second
that's confusing sine goes into cars but
cars goes into minus sign why is that
well let's do a on let's do a quick
abbreviated version of this whole
illustration but let's do it because
there's cost
what's its gradient doing for the first
half of the graph from 0 to 180 what is
the sign of the gradient function it's
negative right
so whatever derivative of God it's gonna
be down here in this region okay and
then of course the second half of it
it's positive ok so if you match up the
sine curve to it here's my gradient it
looks like this which of course is not
sign it's negative sign okay Wow
one more we decide really cuz so next we
should do what a rebel now I'm going to
do you this and make it a little more
obviously okay 10 is just a it's an
identity right for this ratio so what
rule should push it so there's my you
there's my V okay let's do that let's do
have wound on V squared okay how can we
have this V cos x times you - what is
you - this is U so u dash is just cos x
so context times cos x is okay now the
next part is - and then you do the over
the roof so you there's V so it's V dash
minus sine X we just established it
right so I've got two negatives here so
they cancel so this is really cos
squared plus sine squared on top yes so
that's going to turn into an identity we
know the bottom is V squared
okay sorry so go one that's the path
accorded any bit on cos square so I mean
you could leave it like that but it's
simpler to use the reciprocal identity
okay so the derivative of tan is equal
to sex where okay sir
that was my intuitive approach basically
we're just looking at it and I
remembering what is the doing room about
it's just about gradient right and you
can see it sort of follows his pattern
but you can probably tell so I don't
know how you're feeling in your seats
right now you're like I'm not really
that sold on it I mean this was sort of
shady it was kind of like let's sort of
close you know it's not okay so that's
why these earlier steps are about being
more rigorous in that approach okay so
he's mine to approach and these are all
correct results by the way so don't you
know scratched out of your board
but what we're gonna do is go one step
up the ladder let's approach this using
first principles okay sir I'm gonna rub
this off